joining us now from the new orleans
saints
on the phone the great pro bowler the
defensive lineman one of the best in our
games a six-time pro bowler
cam jordan welcome to the show how are
you sir
uh you know i'm good i'm good i'm
surprisingly better than i normally am
uh of the last it's called nine seasons
of super bowl sundays
or super bowl weekends um i processed my
loss you know
and i'm looking forward to getting back
in the lab getting better
what was this season like now that
you've had a couple of weeks to to step
back and look at it because we heard
from the commissioner yesterday cam it's
his annual you know thursday state of
the league thing
and no one's doing a victory lap but the
idea that we have played 268 games now
with 269 coming up on sunday
was there ever a point this year where
you thought man this
this is just a pain and not worth it
uh anytime i'm on the football field
it's always worth it anytime you're
you know in locker room around your
teammates who
work so hard to do everything they could
to
you know play these games it's always
worth it
um i mean it's a blessing to say we got
through a full
16 games then we went through playoffs
um
that made it worth it you talked about
you know from myself
you know playing 10 years of football in
this nfl has been a blessing
that made it worth it i mean there's so
many makes it worth it that
you know the the daily test the
protocols that we had to go through
that's something that you had to pay
price this year to
have a chance to play and really
unlike any other year that made a super
bowl even that much more
coveted i mean there's so many things
that you had to do to even
have the the right to take the field to
have a right to
fight for playoffs to have a right to
get to the playoffs
and it's great perspective because i
don't want anyone to think that uh
the world is too tough on football
players or us in the media or anyone in
the nfl machine as well because
like somehow it's harder for us than for
the people out there i think through all
of it
it gave people something to watch on
sunday which is an old cliche but hey
this is what we're here for to make
people happy but i do think that this
year more than ever
um that did really become part of the
conversation part of the reason why
everyone did go to work every monday and
thursday and friday and saturday and
sunday and here we are
getting ready for super bowl sunday with
two teams
cam that you guys faced this year
talking to cam jordan of the saints on
the rich eisen show
when you faced the chiefs earlier this
year did you walk away from that game
going that's a super bowl team
yeah i mean they just got done you know
winning super bowl i think
i'd use the term before you know you
can't say that you're not at the top of
the mountain until
somebody knocks you off of it um and the
chiefs won
last won the super bowl last year and
look every bit as talented as the roster
they had last year if not now there's
more veterans on the team
what's it like to chase patrick mahomes
because it seems like he runs
he looks like he runs like an old man
but it also feels like it's a bit of a
rope-a-dope
no that doesn't run like oh man tom
brady runs like oh
but don't you see a little bit of a
similar i mean look tom brady is like a
dinosaur
like i mean he's a statue back there but
but patrick's kind of got like that
tiptoe kind of thing you know what i'm
saying
it's deceptive look he's faster than
anybody look you're like oh yeah i can
catch him and then you realize he's
wheeling
um you got to put a little more effort
into cutting off his path
uh but you knew that going into the game
i mean his ability to
uh shake out of the pocket you know make
these wild plays
again he's he's one of those
quarterbacks that you don't know
how or when or where he's going to throw
the ball i mean he'll stay in the pocket
release
but once he gets out he gets super i
wouldn't even say elusive but he gets
super wild i mean he'll
the roll left roll like roll right step
through the pocket you know go across
the line but he also take off
um it sort of disrupts your your
password plan
uh because you don't know where he's
going to be i i want to ask you about
these two quarterbacks
and what they're like talking back there
when you hit him or you get near him
like andrew luck was was famous for
thanking people for sacking him hey guys
hey that was great man thanks great
good hit mahomes seems like every the
nicest guy in america he is when you
meet him
what is he like back there does he talk
to you guys at all
not really i mean he's so where he's so
probably
amped up about the next play you know we
hit him with him quite a few times in
our game you know
um and he's like shake it off it's
probably because he's still so young i
mean he shakes it off and gets right
back to the huddle
um and he knows he has electric
playmakers at every
level you know from wide receiver to uh
running back to
you know just backfield to you know
tight end um
you know he he's so eager to get back to
it you know whereas tom brady
he's so calm cool collected and seen
every every situation in the game when
he gets hit he just automatically trying
to speed up the game
he's trying to figure out how not to get
hit the next play um now if you hit him
you know three four times a row that's
when you can start affecting him that's
when you start you know when he starts
arguing with the office or
yelling at the officer alignment if you
can get that tom brady you might have
some success
um we all know that you know he gets the
ball fast you know
gets the ball out faster than anybody
else in the league
and if he gets hit his timing only
speeds up that's
what makes him so special that that's
that's got to be a good feeling though
when you do hear tom brady getting fired
up and arguing with his guys
and lobbying the officials and telling
the o-line
we have to do better i hear you
but then again that release just gets
faster i mean
if anything you know tom brady is is one
of the greatest to do it
for everything that he is and i mean we
all know he's not going to beat you with
the feet but
his mindset and his his ability to adapt
is second
second none first amongst all talking to
cam jordan of the saint six-time pro
bowler getting ready for super bowl 55
coming up on sunday uh cam when when we
last saw you guys in the field we saw
drew brees walking up the tunnel looking
over his shoulder
and then we saw brees and brady on the
field afterwards you know where i'm
going here with this
did you play that game knowing that
if you don't win this was it for drew
uh no um you know i i go into you know
every playoffs thinking we want we have
these goals that we want to accomplish
uh nfc south check you know playoff
secure
check um and maybe that's the opposite
way
maybe it's playoff check then nfc south
check um
and then you know we want to go nfc
championship
uh in nfc championship game then of
course super bowl um
and those two boxes have been unchecked
uh
for my entire 10 years we've made it to
the game but we haven't beat so
for us you know we're trying to win each
and every year to be the best team that
in
in the um so for drew
maybe to wrap it up this year that i
don't have anything to say on that
person because i don't know what's going
on drew's mind
uh you know the wager finished his last
two seasons you know he's had some sort
of
uh aggravating injury that has taken him
away from
the game that she clearly loved and you
know what he means to this team is
something that you can't replace
so i haven't had to cross the bridge
where he's retired because in my 10
years i've never played without drew
brees being the
qb one at helm at least for the majority
of the season
um so i guess i'll worry about that if
that was his last game
in a couple of couple months or you know
when he decides to clear
cam was there anything this year i'm not
asking you to
to betray anything drew might have said
but was there anything this year that
kind of felt like a last dance thing
you know did he have a documentary crew
following him was he taking
you know little mementos from stadiums
or things like that you know what i'm
saying
yep no the only last dance i know the
michael jordan uh last dance that got
released this
past office you know last off season
which was phenomenal
and that's what i'm getting at yeah
other than drew brees
every every every snap he took was super
focused every
you know uh every game he tried to be
lazy then as you can
um it just happened the last game we
played you know things didn't fall our
way
dude tell me about your podcast you're
doing
uh b trust levels you know me and my one
of you know one of my best friends with
my dogs like legitimately
you know a guy who i came into the
league with um you know
i was drafted pick 24 he was drafted to
pick 28 mark ingram
the second you know father two mark
kingdom the third son of mark ingram
senior
but you know this is the legacy connect
from you know my dad playing league hit
that play in the league us being in a
part of the saints
together for eight years before he went
on to the ravens um you know that's my
connect to my guy you
we really just made it to feed off of
each other's energy and
um have the most fun we can and and our
ability to
uh interact with teammates previous
teammates or
you know just friends across the league
and have some fun doing it so he created
uh you know big trust levels podcast big
trust levels uh but his trust levels and
you know we went through our first
season had 10 or 11 episodes
which was uh you know just a great
showing of how much fun we can have and
we're looking
looking forward to this next season
eventually going to start on
probably the next month or two any
chance uh big trust guy comes back and
plays with
with you guys again man i'm not saying
i'm lobbying
i'm not saying but you know if there's
the opportunity that arises i
i couldn't ask for a better teammate
when you talk about the energy mark
ingram brings to the locker room
uh just his positive mindset on offense
as well as what he brings to
uh the field i mean there's you don't
have
that high of a caliber of an integrity
of a baller on the field
than mark ingram i mean there's a couple
guys like in the league
i think just in terms of energy level
but if
if you know you put them in a category i
put myself in that category
there might be five guys in the league
with that much energy yeah and it was
disappointing for me you know just
watching from afar that he didn't suit
up for most of the second half because
i i get it you're older you got younger
guys he's not playing special teams you
can only dress so many backs but part of
that energy
that he brings to me has to be worth
something regardless of how many carries
just my opinion he would get
on a sunday um but hopefully he finds it
interesting
that he just came off of yeah exactly
from afar was was definitely tough
it was it was tough i know contractually
cam i'm supposed to as a host on super
bowl week ask you who's going to win
um you're probably sick of that question
and probably going to play it right down
the middle
so i'll put it this way how about this
considering the battles you guys had
this year
in the division with the tampa bay
buccaneers are you rooting for the
kansas city chiefs cam
you know i think i think they've got a
lot of good guys on tampa you know um
i'm rooting for defensive line play if
you want to know the honest truth
i like the i like the idea that the
d-line is the most effective piece of a
team
um and i do think um maybe i'm biased in
that and that
jaded way of thinking but i like the
the ideas of you know jpp and shaq
barrett with the dominican supervisor
uh being able to attack the homes i i
relish the idea that you know my guy
alex okafor may get a second ring
um you know you've got fred clark over
there and then you got big chris jones
who's been balling
you know the last three four years uh
and um in a major way to
try to affect the game because it's
gonna be up to that middle push to get
tom brady off the mark and make him
uh you know way be more uncomfortable
than he's ever been
if they could do that there's going to
be large success for that team
um so i'm a i'm a d-line guy and i don't
know who the heck's going to
i i get it i totally get it and and
before i let you go i i do think it
brings up a good point as well talking
to cam jordan here the saints
the fact that the the chiefs are going
into this game without their starting
left tackle they're starting right
tackle in the week of the super bowl
they are pasting together a new
offensive line
against todd bowles and that bucks front
seven people
in the fantasy world we live in cam and
you know this
look at the shiny object and they want
to talk about tyreek hill
racing scotty miller and they want to
talk about
who's the goat and how many rings the
quarterbacks have
you are playing the super bowl cam
without your starting
offensive tackle shouldn't that be the
number one headline
no um when you talk about what pat
mahomes does i mean there's more time
than not that he's
running through you know elongate the
play with his feet
so it doesn't matter you're saying yeah
i mean same thing with tom brady you
know if he was missing his starting left
tackle starting right tackle
um he's still you know because he's six
five six six
and he gets the ball off as fast as he
does i mean he's a
dick dumb intermediate quick shallow
route i mean he's efficient
in terms of his timing with the ball um
i don't know if that's going to matter
much
that's fascinating seriously i mean
it's fascinating that these quarterbacks
are transcendent to the point
where they can adapt to all the
scenarios around them
and that they could raise the level of
game of everyone they are playing with
and that mahomes is is that guy it's why
by the way this game um i think it's
going to be that good and it's why we
love having you on cam to give us
analysis like that we wish you the best
of luck have a
safe i think off season i i know a year
ago that would sound crazy to say it but
have a safe and healthy uh enjoy the
game sunday hope to talk to you
hope to talk to you soon no doubt uh
i've got one question before i dip out
of here and i appreciate you for having
me
it's a beautiful friday that i'm blessed
to you know be taking a breath and alive
and be well and probably start lifting
and get
headed towards you know next season next
week um
that being said how did you get on the
rich isaac show like andrew how'd this
work
on the rich eisen show huh uh dude he
rich
rich is enroute to tampa right now and i
got called out of the bullpen you know i
mean every
every every good starting staff needs a
bullpen you can't win a series without
one so they they called me out of the
pen i was just
out there in the pen flicking sunflower
seeds
okay there you go
yeah they want to pay me closer money
you know closers make good money cam
teach your kids to throw left-handed and
always be available in the bullpen
they'll always have a career and
a nice house
okay i'm always gonna talk to you dude
have a good one absolutely appreciate
you for having me on
yes sir cam jordan of the new orleans
saints a six-time
pro bowler hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here